a patchwork of soybean and cornfields
stretches across the plain of
blue earth county minnesota the campus
of minnesota state university is in
mankato
the seat of the county it's attracted a
small community of immigrants
in 2012 the county voted for president
barack obama
in 2016 it pivoted to president donald
trump
abdi sabri is a somali immigrant he's
the first person of color
elected to the mankato school board the
democrat
says the evolving demographics of the
county
are at the root of its political
whiplash in 2016.
that really gives a lot of my uh
our our white brothers and sisters a lot
of
anxiety that change uh of
for generations they've they've lived in
you know
uh they feel a sense of belonging and
privilege in the system so that being
threatened
was something that trump exploited
a 20-minute drive away on the duncanson
family farm
they're harvesting the last acres of
corn sold to make ethanol
the pro-business anti-regulation
mindset of the trump administration
i appreciate we don't like people
telling us how or what to
do there's a sense of freedom out here
agriculture and hog production are the
economic drivers of blue
earth county the population is about 90
percent
white according to u.s census data
the county's biggest city mankato is the
site of the largest mass execution
in american history in 1862
38 members of the dakota tribe were hung
after the u.s dakota war trials gwen
westerman
is dakota and the director of the
humanities department
at the university we have to acknowledge
the injustices of the past
according to native news online the
native american vote could be a factor
in swing states such as minnesota
there has been a robust national get out
the vote push
that's one way that our voice can be
heard is to vote and participate in the
process and get in there and help make
those changes
the locals say you won't see many
campaign lawn signs
or hear arguments about the election
though they may disagree about
politics what people value more is what
binds them together
as neighbors natasha name al jazeera
blue earth county minnesota well let's
now speak to jamie fly he's a senior
fellow at the german martial fund of the
united states and he was also
formerly an advisor to republican u.s
senator marco rubio he joins us
now from berlin jamie thanks for being
with us i do know for many people
outside the u.s it does seem crazy that
this whole election restaurant a very
small group of voters in just a few
states
and this time around a few traditionally
red states do seem to be leaning blue
do you think that's because of the
choice between trump and biden or
is it because we're seeing a changing
more diverse electorate
i think it's related to both those
factors as you noted
this election has generated passions on
both sides and so we have the potential
that we're not just dealing with
some of the traditional swing states
which have been contested now
over the last several decades places
like ohio
florida parts of the rust belt
but there are other states that people
are openly discussing possibly flipping
places like texas perhaps arizona and
some of that is just the energy
uh especially on the democratic side in
opposition
to president trump but some of it's also
related to changing demographics in a
number of those states where some of the
democratic party's core constituencies
are a growing segment of the electorate
and the democrats have invested a lot of
energy in this cycle
in actually trying to to draw those
voters to the polls
well two states that we're all going to
be watching very closely tonight florida
and pennsylvania especially given their
number of electoral college votes and
the polling margins that we're seeing
there
president trump is now already insisting
the counting of ballots beyond tonight
which
his standard practice is illegitimate do
you think this is all going to end up in
court
it very well could and that's uh that
would not be unprecedented
uh american presidential elections have
often been
litigated uh certainly in 2000
with bush versus gore but even when uh
it was not
over uh the the actual determining votes
there are always issues related to
voter access uh and a number of
congressional races that often end up in
the courts i think the real challenge is
going to be in pennsylvania in florida
my understanding is that florida starts
counting its
early pre-election day votes
in pennsylvania because of a number of
state practices
a lot of those votes the mail-in ballots
won't actually be counted
probably until election night or even
the day after
and especially given how tight the
margin was uh
last time or was less than one percent
uh where trump
by which trump took the state uh you
could have a very tight margin
and those mail-in ballots uh could
actually
sway the election and that's why it's
going to be incredibly difficult
if uh the election does come down to
pennsylvania to really
determine very quickly what the outcome
is so let me ask you then jamie how much
of a landslide would this election need
to be for biden in order to avoid a
lengthy court battle going forward
i think the big question will be what
happens in florida
if biden is able to capture florida
the electoral map for president trump
becomes very difficult
it's not impossible but if president
trump can hold on to florida and we'll
know
fairly early uh after the polls close in
florida and the count in florida begins
and i think florida has a
history despite despite the mess in 2000
of
counting relatively quickly if we know
the outcome in florida that will be
an early indication of some of the
trends
and whether this is all going to come
down to pennsylvania ultimately
so a couple other states if there's a
major upset in places like georgia
texas states that you would expect
president trump to carry but he does not
that could also make the whole map less
reliant on pennsylvania and give us an
early indication of what's going on
well so much of this comes down to the
electoral college which in itself is
pretty controversial
i know many would argue that the
electoral college actually
disenfranchises voters
in non-swing states because most
campaigning ends up being focused on
those areas and other issues that are
important to voters elsewhere they get
put aside
do you personally think the electoral
college system should still exist
i think it's a quirky system that's
difficult to explain to people
but i do think it ultimately works i
think the founders
established this system for a reason
america has always been divided by
uh urban centers and large
uh rural spaces of america that are
rural
uh there was a desire to make sure that
you didn't just have
people in the cities who had all the
political power
and i think honestly that's going to
continue to be a challenge in american
politics
as the country and the demographics
change and so i think
some of what you've seen with donald
trump's election is a bit of that rural
backlash non-college-educated caucasians
coming out in force to support him
and even if the democrats are triumphant
in this election and take the senate and
complete control of congress
i think many uh republicans and many
people who supported someone like donald
trump are going to still
want to place a lot of faith in the
system to protect their interests and
that's going to be even more important
if you have one party controlling the
white house and uh
and both houses of congress jamie fly
there senior fellow at the german
marshall fund of the united states
great to get your insights here on al
jazeera thanks for being with us jamie
thanks for having me